en el vídeo anterior vimos la curva de
titulación también llamada curva de
valoración de un ácido débil el ácido
acético con una base fuerte hidróxido de
sodio en el inciso
encontramos el ph antes de agregar la
base corresponde a este punto y en el
inciso b encontramos el ph después de
agregar 100 mililitros de la base que
corresponde a este punto en el inciso c
nuestro objetivo es encontrar el ph
después de agregar 200 mililitros de una
solución
0.0 500 molar de hidróxido de sodio
entonces cuántos moles de iones
hidróxido agregamos bueno como la
concentración de hidróxido de sodio es
0.0 500 molar esta es la misma
concentración de iones hidróxido la
concentración de iones hidróxido s
punto 0 500 molar y como la polaridad es
igual a moles sobre litros
nosotros queremos calcular los moles y
de volumen tenemos 200 mililitros pero
si movemos el punto decimal 123 lugares
es igual a 0.2 litros
tenemos 0.2 litros
entonces simplemente multiplicamos 0.05
por 0.2 y esto es igual a 0.01 agregamos
0.01 moles de iones hidróxido a la
solución ácida inicial y con cuantos
moleste ha sido empezamos bueno tenemos
50 mililitros de una solución 0.2 molar
de ácido acético entonces la
concentración de ácido acético al inicio
era 0.2 molar
es igual a los moles entre los litros 50
mililitros es igual a 0.05 litros
tenemos 0.05 litros y para obtener los
moles simplemente multiplicamos 0.2 por
0.05 y eso es igual a 0.01 moles de
ácido acético observen que tenemos el
mismo número de moles del ácido y de la
base y como la base neutraliza al ácido
escribamos la reacción de neutralización
empezamos con una solución de ácido
acético a la que le agregamos una
solución de hidróxido de sodio así que
los iones hidróxido toman el protón más
ácido del ácido acético este protón para
formar h2o y como le quitamos un protón
al ácido acético nos queda el anión
acetato
ch 30 o menos
ahora empezamos con 0.01 moles de ácido
acético 0.01 moles y también tenemos
0.01 moles de la base observen que en
este caso la relación molar es 1 a 1 así
que toda la base reacciona y neutraliza
completamente al ácido presente
terminamos con 0 moles de la base y como
todo el ácido es neutralizado también
perdemos todos los moles del ácido este
es el punto de equivalencia de la
titulación observen que al perder ácido
acético ganamos aniones acetato si
empezamos con cero moles pero perdemos
0.01 moles de ácido acético esa misma
cantidad se transforma en uniones
acetato ganamos 0.01 moles y terminamos
con 0.01 moles de hacer
muy bien una vez que conocemos los moles
de acetato podemos conocer la
concentración solamente necesitamos
saber cuál es el volumen total
regresemos al problema cuál es el
volumen total en este punto bueno
empezamos con 50 mililitros y después
agregamos 200 mililitros 50 más 200 es
igual a 250 mililitros nuestro volumen
total es de 250 mililitros que al mover
el punto decimal tres lugares es igual a
0.25 litros calculemos la concentración
de añón es acetato la concentración de
acetato es igual a los moles entre los
litros es decir 0.01 moles 0.01 entre
0.25 litros 0.25
usemos la calculadora tenemos 0.01 entre
0.25 esto es igual a 0.04 la
concentración de añón es acetato es 0.04
molar entonces en el punto de
equivalencia tenemos uniones acetato en
solución así que el acetato reaccionará
con el agua tenemos a la unión acetato
que reacciona con el agua y esta es una
reacción que en algún momento llega al
equilibrio los aniones acetato
funcionarán como una base y tomarán un
protón del agua con lo que se forma
ácido acético ch 30 h y como le quitamos
un protón al agua nos queda el hidróxido
o h menos
al inicio de esta reacción tenemos una
concentración 0.04 molar de añón es hace
tanto 0.04 y podemos suponer que todavía
no se forma en ningún producto 0 0 ahora
en el cambio una cierta concentración de
aniones acetato reacciona así que
perdemos esa cierta concentración x y
esa misma concentración que perdemos la
ganamos de ácido acético aquí tenemos
más x y por lo tanto también tenemos más
x en el hidróxido finalmente al
equilibrio la concentración de añón es
acetato es 0.04 menos x y por acá
tenemos x y x
entonces si escribimos la expresión de
equilibrio como en la unión acetato
funciona como una base
café que es igual a la concentración de
los productos entre la de los reactivos
tenemos x por x entre 0.0 4x porque no
tomamos en cuenta el agua 0.04 menos x
todo esto ya lo habíamos visto en el
vídeo sobre equilibrio de una base débil
los invito a que vean ese vídeo antes de
ver este muy bien ahora necesitamos el
valor de cabe y lo podemos obtener a
partir de acá
en el vídeo anterior dijimos que el caa
para el ácido acético es 1.8 por 10 a la
menos 5 y sabemos que acá a por café
para un par conjugado ha sido base es
igual a 1.0 por 10 a la menos 14
entonces si sustituimos el valor de k
simplemente calculamos cade y nos queda
café es igual a 5.6 por 10 a la menos 10
ahora si sustituimos el valor de cable
en nuestra expresión de equilibrio nos
queda 5.6 por 10 a la menos 10 es igual
a equis cuadrada entre vamos a suponer
que x es un número muy muy pequeño
podemos decir que 0.04 menos x es
aproximadamente igual a 0.04 entonces
entre 0.04 usemos la calculadora tenemos
5.6 por 10 a la menos 10
0.04 y a esto le sacamos la raíz
cuadrada x es igual a 4.7 por 10 a la
menos 6 x es igual a 4.7 por 10 a la
menos 6 y que representa x bueno
observen que en este caso x representa
la concentración de iones hidróxido así
que esto es igual a la concentración de
iones hidróxido ahora nuestro objetivo
es encontrar el ph pero primero
calculemos el p
h&p o h es igual a menos el logaritmo de
la concentración de iones hidróxido si
sustituimos este valor tenemos menos
logaritmo de 4.7 por 10 a la menos 6
esto es igual a 5.33
o h es igual a 5.33 y finalmente p h
veo h es igual a 14 entonces
si sustituimos el p h nos queda que el
ph es igual a 14 menos 5.33 y eso es
igual a 8.67 este es el ph en nuestro
punto de equivalencia y como esta es una
titulación de un ácido débil con una
base fuerte tenemos una solución básica
en el punto de equivalencia
por eso el ph se encuentra en el rango
de las bases es mayor a 7 encontremos
este punto en nuestra curva de
titulación agregamos 200 mililitros de
la base y el ph es 8.67 entonces al
agregar 200 mililitros el punto de
equivalencia nos queda por aquí
este es nuestro punto de equivalencia
para este ejemplo
finalmente veamos el inciso t nos piden
calcular el ph después de agregar 300
mililitros de una solución
0.0 500 molar de hidróxido de sodio
entonces primero calculemos los moles de
iones hidróxido que agregamos sabemos
que la concentración de iones hidróxido
es 0.0 500 molar y esto es igual a los
moles sobre los litros así que 300
mililitros son 0.3 litros si
multiplicamos 0.05 por 0.3 esto es igual
a 0.015 moles de añón es hidróxido ahora
en el inciso c vimos que al agregar 0.01
moles de hidróxido neutralizamos
completamente el ácido presente entonces
si restamos los moles necesarios para
neutralizar al ácido cuántos moles de
hidróxido nos quedan después de la
neutralización bueno nos quedan 0.005
moles de iones hidróxido entonces como
nuestro objetivo es encontrar el ph
primero podemos calcular el peo h y para
eso calculemos la nueva concentración de
iones hidróxido la concentración de
iones hidróxido después de la
neutralización es igual a moles sobre
litros 0.005 entre cuál es el volumen
total
empezamos con 50 mililitros y después
agregamos 300 así que 300 más 50 es
igual a 350 que es igual a 0.35 litros
usemos la calculadora tenemos 0.005
0.35 esto es igual a cero punto cero 14
la nueva concentración es 0.0 14 molar
ahora calculemos el peo h p
h es igual a menos el logaritmo de la
concentración de iones hidróxido es
decir 0.0 14 entonces menos logaritmo de
0.0 14 esto es igual a 1.85 el p
h es igual a 1.85 y finalmente sabemos
que el ph más p
h es igual a 14 entonces si sustituimos
el peo h nos queda que el ph es igual a
14 menos 1.85 y eso es igual a 12.15 al
agregar 300 mililitros de la base en
dado el punto de equivalencia y el ph es
igual a 12.15 encontremos ese punto de
nuestra curva de titulación agregamos
300 mililitros de nuestra base 300
mililitros y subimos para encontrar este
punto que se encuentra a un ph de
aproximadamente
12.15 éste es el ph en nuestra curva de
titulación